[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima
i'm denny direct oh of course the Oscar
nominees have come out this morning
Jenny and I are feeling very musical a
la lala land we're almost at the finish
finish line of this award season guys I
mean the Oscars the biggest show of
awards season arguably so we are going
to be breaking down the big takeaways
from this list of nominees the snubs the
surprises the record setters we're going
through it all so Best Supporting
Actress you guys some really really
awesome things to say about this
category so we have Viola Davis in
fences Naomi Harris for moonlight Nicole
Kidman for Lion Octavia Spencer for
hidden figures and Michelle Williams for
Manchester by the sea an awesome take
away from this category it is the first
time that multiple black actors have
been nominated in the Best Supporting
Actress category of course with Viola
Davis and Octavia Spencer co-stars from
the help idol right girls out there
together I love that about this are they
only an old friend and Naomi Harris oh
there's three in here which is pretty
incredible to see um I think though
there's a clear front-runner in this
race it's been Biola Davis who actually
she also broke a record this is her
third Academy Award nomination she's
been nominated in the past without the
help and now fences I think she finally
is going to take away me gold with this
film I mean she stole she should
honestly stole the movie and she's also
been racking up a lot of awards going
into the Oscars I think it's her to lose
and I think we have we're about to have
that article up on ET online calm but I
believe the record she's broken his
first time that a female black actress
has been nominated three times so it's
so much love for viola I mean she is so
likable she's so lovable and her talent
is so undeniable um so I could
definitely see we were talking about how
she already has an Emmy she has two
Tony's
let's give her an Oscar and then let's
give her the egapp get your Grammy girl
you